you
you
amazing video as always
what's going on everybody so got a
couple PRS in github that I was gonna
poke around with and then I was messing
with one of them
and they seem to do a lot better so I'm
gonna mess with that and then I'm gonna
check out there's still a couple more in
there that I was going to poke through
so so for some reason this one I'm not
really sure exactly why this one doesn't
cause a drop so I'm curious to see what
happens when when it does someone says
there's no this one doesn't fire I hear
the sound here you see what happens when
don't lie to me I definitely have sound
if you don't have sound I'm not sure
what to tell you so first I'm just gonna
see the camera should turn on so I just
want to see if it's to the right camera
as the tables not plugged in i I guess
the owners plugged in I didn't remember
leaving that plugged in yeah okay so let
me just exit this one
yeah so this is this puck filtering one
and and then I just kind of merged the
code to it I only made it like I
basically made the striking and all that
like all it was doing was filtering for
the puck but then also probably the only
thing I added to that logic was well
first of all I'm bringing in the rescale
factor that way I can just modify the
rescale factor we're not working with
straight pixel values so like this was
checking to see if the radius of the
circular object that it finds is great
at least in the code was greater than 10
but we didn't have a it needed to be
less than some sort of number right
because the puck doesn't change in size
so so I went ahead and added a radius
less than 2 and then I just did the
rescale factor so so I should be able to
come in here and rather than maybe half
screen we should be able to say hey I
want the fold 1280 by 720 resolution
what do I do other than coding mostly
car stuff so I like working on cars and
taking cars to track that kind of stuff
now I don't even see the screen anyway
yeah so now we can make the screen you
know full size at least for the camera
and it still works but let me turn the
air hockey table on and let's see if
this arm still freezes when two cameras
are on
not jazz yet I mean I didn't figure it
out in the other one but at least this
one doesn't seem to be freezing so like
this is some PR could and I just want to
see if with on both like cuz I I was
thinking it was probably a USB bandwidth
thing that was just kind of locking
things up but anyways let me just move
the puck real quick oh my god
so anyway the the PR code that and we
got the autofocus on I need to fix that
too anyway now atleast it doesnt lag
when it strikes if we could just keep
the puck from getting stuck that'd be
cray could you make the color of the
circle is pink or yellow I'm not sure
what circle you're talking about yeah
there have been a few improvements I was
just telling them that this the puck
detection is from a pull request that I
got yesterday and then I made some
modifications to it it's anybody has
some suggestions on how we stopped it
from getting stuck in the corners like
that that's pretty annoying I'm I think
I'm just putting something in the way
they're not really sure
please explain the project for people
who don't know I mean I feel like it's
pretty obvious but it's a robotic arm
playing air hockey that's about it yeah
this is OpenCV for recognizing things
yeah so anyway yeah this one's Oh Mike
much better now the puck just gets stuck
but anyway yeah this one's a whole lot
better and honestly the logic for
tracking the puck and hitting the puck
or I guess for the arm to track the puck
and hit the puck is no different than
what we were doing yesterday it's just
slightly different code for actually
tracking the image of the puck which
seems to have made all the difference
and I I cannot for the life of me figure
out why yesterday's code was freezing in
today's code doesn't freeze and honestly
actually I was working with this
yesterday so I'm not really like a
computer restart wouldn't be the answer
either now we just need to figure out
some way to stop it from getting stuck
should use I would like to use I wanted
them to send me two arms so I could have
an arm on both sides but they they
haven't sent me a second one yet if
anybody wants to send me a second arm
have at it a sweeper arm that drives the
puck back
it's just starts to get really really
expensive in terms of how many arms
we're gonna be using so if I keep moving
the arm back I've tried doing that
doesn't really seem like though I don't
know though the arm starts getting
really messed up if you keep if I keep
moving it back I'd thought about that
and I don't see why when I watch the
video and watch it play it would make a
big deal but will you release the source
code
yeah the source code is already well
actually so the code that I'm running
right now is a modified version of the
PR request so in fact I can push that
right now though just in case someone
wants to modify it further
so it took the PR because the PR
requested was or
see her request the PR was sorry guys I
just woke up so haven't had on my coffee
yet give me a moment
the PR was basically just to run on the
video that I posted so it didn't
actually know much about striking and
all that kind of stuff so anyway yeah
let me let me modify the
and fix this part too
okay I'm just really enjoying this putt
getting stuck every five seconds at
least it's not the arm getting stuck
that was way more way more annoying
so I think the one I was using yesterday
was the air hockey stream code so I
think I'm just gonna copy and replace
that code
all right the code that's being run
right now there it is let me fix this
putt now so at this point can the arm
lose in this game absolutely
it's definitely losing a lot cheaper
alternative to the arm for 200 bucks I
mean you could try to build something
and then you could probably build an arm
that's better at like it this whatever
the specific task you're trying to do
the problem is just having all the
degrees of motion and stuff like if you
just need the by like for example for
air hockey there's really no need for
the arm to be able to go like up and
down and hold the same X&Y position as
it goes up and down so if you're just
trying to play air hockey with it you
really just need x and y coordinates or
something so it's a lot less complicated
if you do that I think you need to find
the right you'd probably end up building
your own as my guess I'm not really sure
there's a air hockey robot anyway aside
from whatever it's doing right now it's
not freezing anymore so if anybody can
figure out why why this code doesn't
freeze and why the code from yesterday
freezes I would love to know why isn't
the arm reaching the corner well you
can't see it right now but the arm is
significantly rotated so for some reason
so another issue the arm has is it like
lowers itself and it keeps going lower
and lower or higher and higher so for
some reason the Z coordinates are
getting changed so I tried to remedy
that by basically every time it makes a
strike I raise it where's the strike
here we go era I'm lowering the arm
that's probably too much because now the
arms like literally lifting itself off
of the box and pivoting off the box I
think it's actually trying to escape
that's that's my guess
let me just change that something better
what prescription are my glasses
um why don't they forget I buy them
online though so I have to fill it in a
lot couldn't I can't I can't remember
off the top of my head I don't know if
it's written on the glasses sometimes it
is but these are just like online
glasses sorry I can't tell you I know
that's a really important question
yeah the arm is just currently lifting
itself basically off this box let's see
if we can reset it it really is what
prescription do you think my eyes are I
think it's three and a half and four you
know negative three and a half and
negative four something like that I
think that's right but I could be
totally wrong does the arm have sensors
yeah there aren't I mean it has some
sensor so like the suction cup for
example like senses when it's actually
like grab something the gripper knows
when it's actually grab something but
other than that it doesn't have like
distance sensors you can attach distance
sensors or you can attach a camera and
all that stuff but other than that no
naked seven yeah I pretty much I think I
just destroyed my eyes as a kid I I
really enjoyed staring at flashlights
when I was like a really young kid like
three years old if I could find myself a
flashlight I would stare at it and then
pull away the flashlight and think it
was cool that I couldn't see and then I
needed glasses working at the computer
has had no effect on my eyesight it was
really just staring at flashlights it
seems it seems to do the trick
nothing just let go that puck so fast
have you considered doing this on Twitch
so with I mean like obviously there's
wow did it just I really want to try I
just wanted to see if this would play
long enough with this new new drop but
it's just so kicking it off
why should I trim stream it on Twitch
you can be pretty confident I'll never
put something on udemy I'm not a fan of
you dim
Chatto monopolies that would be crazy so
at the end of the bots can just get
super frustrated with each other in
fight monopoly would be interesting
sorry you mix with the computer and the
computer probably won't steal from the
bank but we could code that in I guess
hmm
he's free to not doing udemy
not sure exactly what that means but now
honestly don't see the point need any I
think if I if I track how much money
I've been able to make by doing like
free tutorials I think at any step of
the way you could sell out and go to
udemy and make a good chunk of change
but as soon as you start putting things
on udemy you're like you're not gonna
grow so like if I had started putting
tutorials on udemy you've got a you've
got a paywall that stops any growth
that's gonna occur why not make free
tutorials
everybody gets access to it for free and
because they're free the network can
grow so much quicker from people that
are able to access your course it just
makes so much more sense to make it free
I mean you'll really you make enough
money on ads and then besides ads you
can do like contracting consulting which
is what I do or you can take like
sponsors or stuff like that
and I just think the growth of having
something totally free is just as good
if not better than the money that you
would make from udemy like let's say
stretched over the course of one year or
two years or something like that and
then the added benefit that everybody
gets by having access to the content
without having to pay anything is just
cherry on top do I live alone no I'm
married
how old is Python programming in that I
don't know four or five years I'm not
really sure
so I came up with the idea for the doing
air hockey because I was watching their
like the you arm your arm has like a
kickstart I can't remember his
Kickstarter IndieGoGo don't have any
course and you did no I don't have any
courses on udemy there's one from like a
company that I did like white labeled
basically so there's no like face cam or
anything like that no mention is sent X
and it's different from the content that
I have on YouTube but if you see
anything that matches any of the content
on YouTube that's not mine well it's
mine but I didn't put it up there
no I don't do I mean I do a lot of
contracting insulting and Finance with
Python but aside from training Bitcoin
automated I don't trade any like stocks
or anything like that automatic no so I
don't have anything on flask on udemy if
there's one up there that's not mine
it's fraud which IDE I'm pretty sure it
says I mean you can read it right right
up here
sublime text okay I'm gonna try so
another one of these one is from 21
hours ago update to the stream code I'm
not really sure what the update was
might help the lag when did you party
last time depends what your definition
of a party is I think probably my
definition is different than yours have
you heard of Adam yeah I use the Adam
editor it's like that I think as Adam is
the default on paper space that was
pretty fun I'm really not if I if I
drink I just get super chill and I can't
hear things like if I'm in like at a
loud environment I just I just zone out
basically so so if I get drunk I just
sit and kind of just chill on a couch
somewhere that's about it I might talk
to like one person or something or go to
sleep
yeah tensorflow ajs is interesting I
keep looking into tensorflow @j s hoping
to I've got an idea of what I'd like to
do with it
the real bummer with tensor like the the
demos are super cool and you can do like
object detection and you can do some
cool stuff with it but it's really from
Osan your computer then go do your demo
on like your cell phone and it's really
frustrating yeah so it works really well
on computers now but it's almost like
with tensorflow das it's like this
technology that's here now but we're
still waiting on the hardware to catch
up which is kind of annoying but it's
it's super cool and I want to play with
it but I wish I could come up with
something that would work on like both a
cell phone like an average cell phone
and and a computer what are the
companies offered full-time job after
starting this YouTube channel
I don't think I've ever I mean so
Facebook reached out you bir has reached
out I'm trying to think any other big
companies that you would know of
there's definitely quite a few companies
have reached out but I'm just not really
that interested in picking up another
job like why would I do that like most
of those jobs don't offer the same
amount of money I make just by doing
free tutorials so why would I leave and
then also you got to live in California
where cost of living like you're gonna
you you're gonna pay like sixty thousand
dollars a year just to survive doesn't
seem to make much sense
I'm trying to pull up the code for the
the chin okay so this one was just to do
a buffer size so I did I did actually
try that and that didn't really it
didn't help any of the the actual
freezing and you have to listen to your
boss I mean if I if I respected a boss I
think that would be fine
you just have to I think you just you
just have to find a good boss and that's
probably the one thing that actually
probably exists at like top-end type
companies is you probably actually have
decent bosses that you can respect but
yeah that's that's what you need and
like you know doing stuff on your own
you can so you know you want to go fast
you go alone you want to go far you go
with the team but it's really difficult
to find a good team so I'm actually I'm
not even gonna bother with this one this
one was just for the buffer size and I
did try that I can't remember if it
helped the frame rate at all but but
they didn't solve the lag it was
actually this code here that solves the
freezing it hasn't frozen yet so that's
really exciting glad we got that solved
that was annoying although I don't even
know I don't even know what was the
solution there how to become Centex
in Python and machine learning stuff
well thank you for the super chat and so
I think probably the biggest thing is
just like just I would just do pretty
much like exactly what I've been doing
so I think a lot of people might get
stuck like with anything like reading
books or like learning the content
rather than actually doing the content
so at least for me I've gotten a lot of
success out of actually like when I when
I learned something I go and teach it
and the act of actually teaching it I
mean just paid pays huge dividends
because you you immediately find out
what you don't fully understand like
you'll be writing it out and you'll
write out some parameter or something
and if you're teaching somebody or
you're just even if you're filming it
toriel or you're just doing a text-based
write-up on your blog or whatever you're
gonna realize oh I don't really know
what this is Xena and you can take the
easy route and just kind of skip over it
and gloss over it or you can go back and
figure out what that thing is or how
that works or whatever and that that
really helps so at least for me someone
else asked about books I don't know
where that went
I get asked for programming books all
the time I have not read a single
programming book besides the programming
book I helped rewrite basically updated
a programming book for I think it was a
press four PI game and other than that I
mean the the problem with books is
they're always gonna be like outdated
and the publisher is gonna always want
to have three four hundred pages so so
it's just gonna be like stretched out as
far as it can go and then also just the
whole writing process takes a
significant amount of time so at least a
year so people are probably the biggest
one right now just cuz machine learning
is so popular people are like what a
machine learning books well none of them
because by the time that book you know
someone writes that book gets it to
publish and now it's out and then
finally get some like people reading it
and reviewing it it's probably like two
years old or something in the field is
changing too much I mean I just don't
see the point
especially when you can find all the
information to anything you want online
so and that's that's how I've learned
everything I've gotta have a degree in
this I don't none of that like I didn't
read any books you can just google all
your questions and that's it yeah
that's pretty much what I think by the
time the books are written it's already
outdated and it's just made to be as
long as possible and I just I find books
super tedious plus with programming like
I want to work with the book and like
you you can program alongside like
reading a book sure I just I'm way more
efficient on the computer so I it might
just be I'm different like that's
totally fine like if you find yourself
if you have good results I guess from
reading books I mean I keep doing it
it's just I have no suggestion for you
YouTube handles currency conversion on
the fly and does it why do you think
that handled it is that the is it the
message that pops up at least in super
chat I don't see a conversion on the fly
I don't know if stream Labs is doing it
no I'd love to know what the conversion
is also I can't read that message I have
no idea what that said I'm gonna have to
translate that usually you can just
right-click and translate why can't I do
that
move this over here just in case
the new pasta you have the same voice
what's going on I consumed him
okay teach the hand to move the puck out
of the corner yeah it's been sitting
there for a while hasn't it I'm not
really sure Oh someone else you guys
need to translate it quicker for me so
anyways he wants yeah I don't know how
to get the puck to be moved out of the
corner one option I thought is if if it
we at least notes in the corner and so
like you'll notice like in the code
yesterday I had it if it was in this
position the whole time it would it kept
trying to strike the puck because it was
greater than 0.8 and so instead what I
did is change it so if the puck is also
it needs to be less than 0.9 fork so if
it's more than 0.9 for like 0.96 you
know it's beyond the arm it's like over
here now how to get it from that point I
don't really know I'm not really sure
you could maybe have some sort of
process that like takes the arm in front
of it and then just drops down but every
time I've tried messing with that it the
the puck just he just loses the puck and
so that's hard yeah I wish so actually
what I was thinking is putting something
in the corner to block it that's that's
how I tend to think is just drop
something in there dude play fortnight
I'm not sure people would appreciate it
a small fan it turn that actually
probably could work if you put like
little pc fans in the corner and then
move the move the arm out of the way and
then the fans turn on and move move the
puck it could be done it could be done
can it grab a coffee cup I think the
coffee cup might be too heavy actually I
don't think it would work first day at
work tomorrow as a data scientist
congratulations on job at least and good
luck I hope you didn't lie on your
application or anything otherwise I'm
sure he'll be fine what's going on Scott
so while that's stuck I'm just gonna go
over to this one so it has so this
improves puck tracking and adds the
automatic field detection let me open
this and check this video over here
first okay
seems legit so I guess edge detection or
something like that's being used so then
we wouldn't have to keep changing it
can't the arm move up
yeah the arm can move up what would you
like to do with that arm moving up is it
true that coffee in America is very
light I don't think so
I mean you coffee in America is like
infinite choices sure you can get
anything you want
following random links well I mean it
was a submission in a whole request not
get it seems safe enough
so this is reading in from the oh did he
change I guess he changed the code for
me already all right I appreciate that I
thought I was gonna have to swap the
code to work with the camera feed rather
than the video
I hope after a year it'll be really good
at air hockey if that's the case if it's
still playing air hockey a year later
oh this is I didn't copy it over looks
like this looks really familiar from
before
a Roomba bot play air hockey I don't
think you'd want to make a Roomba bot
play air hockey I do have a Roomba
though I used to have a thing called Bob
sweep which is pretty nice
but it would like like a Roomba as it
approaches a wall like slows down and a
lot of times doesn't have to even touch
the wall but the Roomba
remember goes like this wall and then it
backs up sorry for the headphone users
but then but but the I'm sorry the Bob
sweep smashes into the wall and then
after it's been say I don't know a year
or something the little front sensors go
bad and then the Bob sweep just like
goes in a circle if it didn't slam into
walls that wouldn't be a problem you
know what I really want to try those
like one of those little yard mowing
BOTS I would like one of those
oh my gosh this has been modified from
the pump oh we got to change it to use
the gripper I'm just gonna do this I
just want to see it detect so we don't
need to set pump true expected radius
not defined
I feel like expected radius shouldn't be
a parameter at all I should just be
diameter divided by two
we'll see
challenge accepted I'll make room but
so I think what I'm gonna do is let me
just fix this real quick so expect the
diameter any time we have expected
radius I feel like you should just be
able to replace that with diameter
divided by two I'm not really sure why
you'd why you'd even have an expected
radius if radius hey right here wow
you're really giving me a hard time
so what if we just replace expected
radius with expected diameter divided by
two
replace all see what happens that's
detecting a lot of the green it could be
the his defense that could be the ruin
it's super laggy it could be the the
camera settings so I could change the
camera settings and that might help
have you ever thought of trying hard
coding and Python what you are doing now
I'm not sure exactly what you are
calling hard coding in this case but I
don't know if you mean actually just
writing everything from scratch or hard
coding as in no variables so at least in
this case man there's a lot of freezing
yeah every time the arm moves this is
getting frozen I think I'm gonna and
it's this is appearing to have the same
problem as the original be gone I do
like the automatic ROI though actually
let me see how how he was doing that
because we could probably add that in
but the problem is you don't really want
to do that once
if table is found use it otherwise ask
the user to select
so we could add that and could maybe
take that
yeah writing everything from scratch it
wouldn't work there's no way I could do
like image processing I mean it would
just take me a long time for sure if
you've impossible it would just be super
slow like getting a good framerate
writing it from scratch and Python like
I bet a lot of OpenCV just isn't Python
it's probably C C plays blues I'll
probably I'll probably take this
automatic ROI though I like I like the
idea of that so maybe I'll borrow that
mmm but we have to take this contours
code too I guess
how much do you code every day I don't
know I'd probably average 10 to 12 hours
it's a lot of time I spend I don't know
though because a lot of times on the
weekends I don't I don't know to be
honest especially if you factor in like
eating and doing other things
watching YouTube doing nothing how do
you not get burnout you enjoy doing
whatever it is that you're doing I just
work on fun projects like I definitely
get burnt out like doing like
contracting your consulting stuff yeah
that's a recipe for getting burnt out
for sure but if it's like your thing or
something you're really interested in
that's how you don't get burnt out
so I think I'm probably gonna
incorporate this but I'm gonna skip that
for now and I'm gonna come back to here
and probably the change I wouldn't mind
making is as the puck is coming in like
diagonally a lot of times we miss the
puck by just going straight forward and
it would make so much more sense to to
try to hit the puck towards wherever the
puck is coming from like that just makes
a lot more sense
so like when the puck if the puck was
like right here striking perfectly
forward works but let's say the arm is
here and the puck is like here I don't
know if you can see that yeah good you
don't want to straight forward you want
to strike like towards the putt and so
we could try to take like the pucks
location and then take the arm and
strike towards the puck or something
like that and that would probably help a
lot especially when the development yeah
definitely like it at the beginning scar
its things are just like way more
exciting and then as time goes on and
you've got to like fine-tune the code
and all that kind of stuff like
definitely gets a little more tedious
but then you just like walk away again
if it's your own project like at any
point if you're getting bored or tired
or stuck or whatever you just walk away
or just go do something else a lot of
times I'll go for a run or go work out
or something like that and like or just
go to sleep
that helps
so let me take so we take the puck X
probably what we ought to do before we
take like actually strike at the puck
would be we would want to pick so the
puck accent yeah the puck Y is should be
a percentage so this puck Y and then
don't we
I thought we had to get position for the
arm I don't think we actually do that's
gonna be another command that could
probably cause trouble but we'll see I
feel like I answered are you married
like 10 minutes ago at least I heard do
Python
no I'm actually married
so I think I forget the order but we
should we can we should be able to get
away with Swift dot get position and I
forget the order of that but we could
probably determine it soon Doug Doug
children no maybe one day little Centex
juniors running around
did I not print our Oh it's only as it
goes to do a strike I see okay hold up
let me close this here we go
so X Y and your Z
so straight-arm y equals we're not going
to get away with that I don't think
why to use Windows Windows is just a
user more user friendly I agree that
Linux is more developer-friendly and
then Mac OS is probably a great
in-between I just simply do not use it
so probably the biggest thing with any
Apple product is you just can't you
can't build it without like each one you
just can't build it but like like with a
like for me I can build a really high
end Windows machine for you know
probably 1500 bucks or something like
that and if I really like if I wanted to
load it on like GPUs or whatever and
have like a really nice deep learning
machine still like 2500 dollars or
something like that although now with
the freaking 1080 T eyes and all that's
a little more expensive since people
bought it out but I think if if you
don't build your own machines then sure
max a good slightly overpriced product
but if you're used to being able to get
hardware and just build it yourself what
you know Mac is really hard to justify
unless you're getting like a laptop or
something like that but even now you can
start building laptops in I think that's
the problem I understand like why Mac
has to be so expensive but whatever I
know people that have Mac's and
especially like the laptops or even like
the desktop PCs and stuff and they have
nothing but good things to say about
them so except for the price so I guess
that justifies the price maybe maybe
so puck why trying to think of how I
want to do getting the the negatives and
stuff like that so I think we'll
probably the way I would do it is or
forearmed why how do you use a GPU for
machine Allah khuda someone else's code
I'm not sure what your question is their
decoder how how you use a GPU you
install tensorflow GPU
use Mac and Windows like what would you
you what why do you use Mac or like why
would you use one over the other
how don't you use a GP that's the
question
you don't yeah you don't don't use a GPU
unless you want to do like the samples
or something like that you can get by
with a CPU or if you're just running a
model you can run it on the CPU like our
chat bot runs on a CPU I just you know
if you're just doing one thing at a time
that's not too bad but yeah if you're
trying to train in like batches of 100
samples or something like that it starts
getting really really slow it can be
done though I just wouldn't I wouldn't
wish it upon my enemies favorite piece
of hardware 10 atti at least at its fair
market value it's a MSRP it was a it was
like the best priced GPU you could
possibly get by far honestly it was
probably under priced I don't know if
they set that price specifically because
they just wanted to move units or what
but I mean it just seemed like it was
just crazy ly price for the amount of
power you would get so yeah that was
that was the best but now I think
they're like 1100 or 1200 dollars for a
1080i which is you know a little
overpriced probably for what you're
getting but yeah
Jarvis like a I I think as close as I
would get to a Jarvis would be like a
more like an Alexa hey hey then Jarvis
I'm not sure what I would get Jarvis to
do for me are you freelancer I mean I
guess by the definition of freelancer
I'd call it contracting and consulting
but yeah I do do that
I try to keep that to a minimum though I
don't really I'd rather be doing my own
thing in someone else's now as I was
doing so I think what I'll do is all
plus so it kind of do the same thing
that I did to get I thought I made it
like I thought I've made this
calculation before
I guess it was just here
so it's not quite the same so I'm pretty
sure to get the arms percentage location
because it's in the negatives we want to
do plus this so we get the number plus
my max and we would want to divide that
but then we're gonna have to translate
it back out to I don't know if I really
wanted to anyway let's just try that /
arm why max times 2 so i should
normalize both the puck why in the arm
why
let me just print those out real quick
[ __ ] why arm why and we'll see
yeah Fred honestly Python program in it
so often I just go back to my own
website and get reminded about some
topic or whatever or I just google it
like a lot of times if I can remember oh
I found the answer this on Stack
Overflow I'd like remember the question
I typed him and I get my answer that way
what's my stream in schedule definitely
random now one of the things that was
holding me off from doing streaming was
just the fact that it seems like most
people with streams liked it because it
has to be scheduled and with YouTube
I've never really had to run a schedule
so yeah
just whenever I feel like it I'll
probably pop up a stream for 11 K subs
275 viewers I think that's not too bad
actually and concurrent concurrent views
the worst number is like two 411
thousand subs and then on any let's say
any video would be it's like five
thousand or seven thousand or something
is the average views at the moment where
is everybody it's just different when
like pright no matter what I release
besides maybe ml pretty much ml is
something most people are excited about
but you know think of how many subs I
have and then how many of those people
are interested in let's say a robot arm
it's probably like less than ten percent
or something like that so it's I think
that's probably what causes stuff like
that same thing with like like web
development stuff like that like people
aren't necessarily always interested in
no matter what it is that I post unless
it's super generalized favorite language
apart from Python none none of the above
I found go to be decent actually I guess
favorite line probably Java scripts to
be honest I mean just because you can
you can do such cool things in Java
scripts but I'm so bad at
a script that I feel like a liar if I
say JavaScript but JavaScript just
because of what you can do with it it's
just a cool language
pandaman IBM's released a simulated what
do you mean a simulated quantum
computing library like so it's like in
preparation for quantum computing or
what cool things like what like like
interactive applications stuff like that
like we were talking yesterday about
desktop apps versus like to me like I'm
not sure I'm ever going to build another
desktop app again because what like
what's the point unless a client asked
for one
whereas with because like with
JavaScript you can do anything you want
and just make it a web app so I guess I
just think of JavaScript as my app
making language as opposed to like
Python I just don't like making apps and
Python like desktop apps anyways
do you think we should learn I mean if
you're interested in coding in junior
high but like in junior high I'd I did
not like programming like I tried to
learn programming when I was in like
junior high in high school and I just
didn't like it
it was just not just never clicked I
don't think I ever tried Python though I
think that's that's the problem right
there
wine high school I don't know I think I
think people just teach whatever it is
they learn first of your teacher learned
C++ first or whatever they think
everybody should learn C++ first and
it's just the the tragedy of
standardized education to be honest some
people are probably better off learning
C++ first and then some people are
Python I think people are gonna be
insulted but a lot of times like I
remember there's a question on Stack
Overflow like is anybody ever really an
expert in Python or something like that
I think I stack overflows in reddit and
I think that you've got like programmers
and you've got like power users of a
programming language and I'd like to
think of myself more as like a power
user of a programming language rather
than like a really good programmer but
people that start with something
lower-level like C++ or whatever tend to
become better tend to be better
programmers I guess if they were able to
pick up C++ or some other lower level
language that is whereas someone like me
with Python like I just get good at
using Python to do what I want it to do
like I don't really think of myself as
like a really good programmer like I can
just take the tools I have and use them
to do the things that I want to do but I
don't really think I'm a good programmer
or an expert programmer
so we don't need this print puck Y
anymore a lot of students struggle with
the curly braces I hear that I mean I
think pythons easy for like to me it
still seems like if you're gonna
introduce people if you're gonna that's
why I have cuffs with lids on them
always knock them down anyway I think
for introducing people to programming it
does seem like really rough to introduce
people to to C++ over Python like why
not Python it just seems to be a better
choice in my my opinion but I think if
somebody wants to get like a CS degree
or I don't even know if I would call it
CS anymore but like a programming degree
I think I think you you kind of should
know lower level languages because
Python is not low low level enough for
you to have for sure a full
understanding like I got away with
Python not even understanding
object-oriented programming for a pretty
long time like I got a lot of stuff done
but I think if you're gonna be like a
real programmer you need to need to know
not just object-oriented programming but
like a whole lot more than that like
pointers and that kind of stuff memory
management all that kind to use
metaclasses
no I would probably use code that uses
medical assets that's about it too many
use scratch I think I could agree with
that I think at some point you get like
too low level whereas like with Python
pythons like I feel like I don't know
though like I'd have to go back to my
six-year-old self or ten year old self
and try to read Python and see if I
could actually follow it but I I feel
like this is the reason that I I really
enjoyed Python was just how easily you
could just you could not be a programmer
read a Python script and know exactly
what was going on whereas like I tried
to learn Java for example and I always
needed like the editor what was it
eclipse basically I you could like get
Eclipse to fix your mistakes and like I
could never figure
I don't had to make I couldn't write
there's no way I could write a job as a
program without eclipse to like fix all
my mistakes for me and I don't really
like the idea that I always start off
kids on scratch have you tried starting
people off Scott on on Python or no and
like how old are the kids
like I wonder - you know I think I think
it because it might be like the cases
like people get older they they develop
like different reasoning in their head
and like something like where you like
block programming something like scratch
where it it might just be a thing where
you've got to be you have to be of a
certain age and that like it just might
be like the whole like white space tab
and code blocks all that kind of stuff
maybe that's I don't know I don't know
enough about childhood development to to
really answer that but that might like
stuff like that could be a hurdle for a
for younger children to like pick up
Python maybe I'm not really sure though
I feel like most stem companies start
around 14 yeah I feel like at age 14 you
you should be able to start at Python
but eight for Python is my wife know my
wife's a doctor she she definitely I
think she's the most program and she did
was HTML
well it's my opinion about functional
programming or functional paradigm on
the rise but well whatever gets the job
done I mean I don't I don't really care
I don't care what people use I don't
really care what language people use at
the end of the day we're just trying to
make products that do things and
hopefully do them as fast as possible as
smoothly as possible and then with if
other people are using it you'd need it
to be as securely as possible if they're
out there futher in the terminal
okay so somebody needs to provide some
code now that we have the puck Y on the
arm wine because the pucks traveling so
it's almost like you'd want to take like
the middle point but we need to convert
these to actual coordinates to send to
the Y although part of me thinks that as
long as we travel like we could just
take the puck like what if I wonder if I
just pass
we we might not have even needed to
calculate the arm why like why don't we
just send it to the wherever the puck is
oh this is a new question wanna use
Linux
[Laughter]
do you play clash of clans now don't
play clash of clans I play a see I like
I have a I like the the oculus rift so
there I'll play elite dangerous or
there's a couple other games on there
that are like straight-up
VR games are like racing games old
school runescape do you know a channel
named coding train no I don't know
coding train tensorflow TAS tutorial
I'll check it out
I've I at least right now there's like
this huge gap between you know the docs
for tensorflow TAS and like making a
finished product if he's doing an object
detection I'm gonna rage everybody's
just doing the same thing and they're
just doing object detection copying like
one person's code basically and it's
getting annoying
so I just created this dope website with
Wix did you let me show you how I did it
no you should play clash of clans too
many games man thank you you really need
like one game in your life and that's it
another session of my I should get a
whiteboard I should do it just like this
this is many parts just this is looking
pretty good
I don't know why I've never heard of
coding train it's crazy how many people
are on YouTube and like you just never
hear of them like this guy is like
completely related although let me see
what else he does maybe it just does
everything not just like Python yeah
this is like programming see this guy's
probably a legitimate programmer is this
a difference you have the power user
sent X and then this guy's probably
legit programmer
you didn't answer it's cuz I've answered
the Linux question like a million times
Windows is better for users and so if
I'm doing things like recording a video
editing or if I play a game or anything
Linux isn't just not good at it so I
definitely like I use Linux for all my
servers like all my websites and all
that kind of stuff but no as a main
computer I think you really gotta use
Windows or Mac and that's about it at
what age do I start I think twenty
twenty or twenty one didn't read any
books I started with actually hey that's
a lie I read I don't know if I could say
if I read a book if it was online it was
n ltk org slash book that's how I
learned Python because I wanted to do
natural language processing
other than that though I haven't read
any book and I'm actually not even sure
NL TK org slash book I'm not even sure
there's an actual book like I think they
just called it a book
project in the future I'd like to
continue the self-driving car in Grand
Theft Auto possibly do a first-person
shooter like AI kind of the same idea
just reading off of game pixels I think
that would be pretty cool
coding trained as a live streaming I
thought about doing something like that
too but I hate editing just say doing it
okay every time I do it if I do a video
and if I screw it up or whatever I'll
just rerecord it okay I can't be asked
to do video editing
I I know nothing about programming
neural nets in MATLAB I mean like I was
saying before if it gets the job done
and whatever you're trying to do if you
can do it in MATLAB awesome if you can't
or it's too slow or whatever yeah yeah
Nicolai yeah Cori Schaefer that's
probably the only other channel I really
know much about yeah i that's the one
channel I recommend to everybody so I'm
aware of Cori shaver I was recommending
Cori Schaefer from life when he had like
15 thousand subs okay I'm a Corey
Shaffer OG trust me I think I wish I
think I wish Corey Shaffer would I don't
know how frequently he uploads now but
uh Corey Shaffer let's see if I can find
him let's put him up on YouTube see how
frequently now he's uploading but in the
past it was just way too slow like he
could be a huge channel if he just if he
if he was more active and I don't know
what his you know real life job is or
anything but he could definitely he
could he could go full time YouTube if
he if he wanted to take the jump why
definitely typed in Corey Shaffer and I
landed on Corey Scherer that's not what
I wanted well psyched Ain Corey Shaffer
is 700 thousand subs incredible
preparing some new stuff for 2018 I
don't my search bar on you to someone I
don't know if you guys can put links I
have no idea someone put a link to Corey
shavers channel it's like my search bars
is not working
can't put links I would think you could
link to a YouTube channel though me just
I got is Twitter this is this is the
longest and the most effort I've ever
had trying to pull up a I don't know why
I might
I guess my Internet's just going super
slow thank you Scott
it just isn't loading uh it's just going
unbelievably slow
work from home would be better or full
time in office I mean if you're working
with other people I feel like it's in
your best interest to work like with
them rather than for from home if you're
trying to gain experience or learn about
working with other people and teams and
stuff like that I do feel like if you're
working on it with a team it's better to
be in person I can't load his channel I
don't know what the deal is just so
frustrating it's just like stuck we try
another another browser or something
let's see
hey everybody how's it going there we go
no law
incognito can't solve three weeks.3
weeks.3 weeks and this is o's flask
series yeah losses dated dumped three
weeks ago my gosh so you usually just
post like once a month or something
maybe it's kind of what it looks like
maybe a chunk every once a month anyway
yeah if you've never heard of his
channel check it out
training the robot real-time yes and my
thought was you know you can figure out
where the data to us I honestly don't
know what to think about these as long
as the the content that you put out the
biggest thing is just do people watch it
all the way through and as long as
they're doing that it's okay but yeah if
you if you drop like five videos and
then people watch like the first two
minutes of one of those five videos and
then none of the other five videos
that's going to negatively impact you've
quite a bit do you think in the future
there will be a thousand of machine
learning job no I mean maybe maybe in
the really near future a lot of ml jobs
and then much of me thinks that the role
of the programmers gonna probably that
job is probably a shrink I just think
programmers are gonna program themselves
out of a job that's my guess my goal is
to just be on top of that and be the one
that sells the product that does that
thing yeah yeah I'm pretty confident
they it I'm not really sure it'll be AI
but like for example eventually I think
we'll get to the point where like you
don't have like phone apps necessarily
you've got like one app where you tell
the app hey I'd like a weather app that
notifies me when XYZ happens and I want
you to show me this radius or whatever
and like that's it's just an you just
use natural language to get the app to
do whatever it is that you want to do
that's the end game for all apps all
right and then maybe you could like to
share those apps like app recipes and
you would share them with friends or
whatever but I think eventually there's
just going to be this massive vacuum
that just yeah there just won't be that
many jobs
I don't think and that might take 20-30
years but eventually yeah
really have much faith in it except for
like for hobbies or something like that
I think people still always program I
really don't know I mean nobody can
predict the future so as far as you know
choosing it as a career in the future I
think any career is at risk I think the
same thing like my wife just became a
doctor and she was thinking about going
into surgery and I was like whoa I don't
know about that
I got feel like surgery is a perfect
example I mean we are robots are already
taking over surgery so eventually I
think that's that's a perfect example of
where like people have quicker recovery
times when and they have like less pain
after surgery and you right now we need
humans like oversee the surgery I forget
what they call those BOTS but low calm
surgery BOTS so like right now you still
need a surgeon to like oversee it and
stuff but eventually I mean I just yeah
and I think it'll be cheaper all that
kind of stuff
so I'm thinking of sending this to y
equals I wonder if we could just send it
to because that's a decimal so we really
should be able to just say puck Y times
my max times 2 and then divide it by or
subtract my max the slowest update of
this script ever programming to probably
the last job yeah definitely I mean
because protocol e be programming away
like I think the biggest job will be
programming jobs so I mean it's probably
the most secure job but yeah thank you
for the donation William or the super
chat I can't really tell I guess it's
super chat yeah
yeah can you imagine the the level of I
don't know not stress I don't know the
the the pressure of writing the code for
a robot that operates on people's hearts
or brains wolf same thing we're I was I
think the code for Apollo 11 see Apollo
11
github that's up here on github you can
look at that code
can you imagine writing the code my gosh
like the just the amount of pressure if
it if you screw it up
a lot of meat politics and national
security probably that is like all code
has holes too so I'm not really sure
you'd want to automate politics and
national security because whoever is the
most man can't clear my throat today I
should just be purely talking and
drinking coffee
thanks for the links Scott and I
should've posted the link is it possible
to address each individual joint yeah
yeah you can you can access each like
servo in the Swift robot you can send in
like g-code and all that
okay so I think if we set this position
to that why I think it should strike
towards the puck we're gonna see I need
to put the striker back in it to you
like closes the little gripper way too
quickly I couldn't stick the striker in
there
a minecraft playing AI what would it do
like what would it do in Minecraft
I pull this over for you guys sorry
about that
I feel like that went backwards before
it actually took me the hit I'm not sure
what what I've done wrong here I'm not
sure that's exactly what I was hoping
for am i moving the hand manually no my
hands my puck I feel like it's moving
backwards before it's striking I'm gonna
why would it be doing that at least that
one was pretty good sometimes it moves
backwards which is odd and that was just
the wrong direction
what is the robot doing right now you
tell me me yeah now it's not sure what
it's doing it's it's ragequitting I
think get it
I mean that did pretty much what I was
asking but sometimes it was weird
sometimes it would like
that I hate do we close that off no do
we
fix that
you have to do a little better than that
for Minecraft AI you could possibly make
it so just fights mobs honestly I've
only seen like Minecraft videos
I've never played minecraft controlled
the power it puts in you mean like how
hard it hits or something like that
hold on just totally we've got something
wrong with the mad somebody needs to
help me solve this one I'm not sure why
because here we're getting the
percentage out of double the max because
we go into the negatives and then I
removed the arm why max which is like
that's defined up here which we've done
like the maximum really for the arm is
like 222 negative 220
it seems like when it's out when it's in
the negatives it's like striking the
wrong way like I'm pretty sure when it's
up towards the top that's a negative
please play for a night with ml the
problem with any of those like I want to
do a first-person shooter but
fortnight's too close to like something
like pub G or whatever where the
distance to the person that you like you
that the your ability to detect a player
at a great distance is what is rewarded
in something like like fortnight or pub
G or whatever and that's really hard to
do with just image processing because
you've got it you'd have to take the
image and go like do a slider over just
tiny parts of that image and then doing
that at a high frame rate would be just
super challenging I'm not even I don't
have no idea how you would get away with
doing something like that you probably
get just way too small frames per second
and then if the person is moving or
you're moving or whatever that would be
really challenging why don't you train a
virtual neural network I don't know ask
ask Scott if you mean for the for the
air hockey we have like a real basic
unity version of like playing air hockey
and all that the physics still need to
be worked out
yeah for a night third person I mean you
couldn't you can filter out though the
like if the person is always at like
kind of like the same coordinates or
whatever you could definitely filter
yourself out but you could but like that
was a problem with the GTA like when I
made the basically like the aimbot and
Grand Theft Auto that was kind of the
problem with that was a lot of times it
would detect itself which was annoying
to say the least in this case the IDS
sublime text says at the top so puck
zero I'd have to go back and look I
wonder if we're we are I don't think
we're flipping it though because it goes
puck zero should be all the way to the
top of the screen for for the Y so if if
Y is 0 in OpenCV that's all the way at
the top of the screen so I said it 190
to the max because if we go to 20 and
the bot goes all the way to 220 like
negative 220 it'll go beyond the edge
and just like drop the puck and that's
obviously problematic but yeah so if if
the puck is at 0 the arm should be at
negative you know 190 I think playing
for tonight with ml and then fortnight
Microsoft though that would be a company
that would possibly appreciate ML
playing it I think eventually we we have
to we have to consider laws around
artificial intelligence and not allowing
as a eyes to play a game or buy a
product or whatever I think that's
problematic
yeah the this room should be uploaded
automatically to YouTube I mean look
here
obviously when the puck goes into the
corner that's a problem but it shouldn't
it should still be able to strike at the
puck correctly it almost looked like
when it was when the puck was at the
arms negatives it would strike in the
wrong direction which was a problem
you
so I have a dog that knows how to open
doors
sometimes he just decides he wants to go
outside so he just opens the door and
goes outside he doesn't shut the door
behind him
you program the dog and that dog just
learns how to do things on his own
yeah he'll watch you like open a door or
a gate or something one time and and
he'll figure it out from there
so that was pretty score nice okay so
then that won't I wonder if his just a
delay though like if the puck is moving
too quick I think that's what's causing
the problem because that time it was a
on the positive end great fantastic I
really appreciate that that was pretty
good though one-shot learning dog yeah
whoa
thanks you worm yeah what models he
running he seems pretty good could you
make the putt the problem with that is
we're having a serious problem getting
the puck just to make it reach the other
the other side basically at least with
this code it's happening so you really
could at least get the model to train
itself on some data I feel like I hear
the arm moot okay decide I feel like I
hear the arm moving and it should be off
do-do-do-do-do-do
so here's why I'm not a programmer and
why I'm a power user ready dum-dum
he's not grabbing the puck he needs be
reset I think
[Music]
why don't you specific Python IDs like
PyCharm I just like a nice simple editor
again what just like what language to
use or framework or whatever just use
whatever gets the job done I mean if
you're highly successful in productive
in PyCharm use Python I feel like I'm
gonna have to I'm not really sure if
it's uh if it's like because the arm is
lagging that it's missing the puck or
what I'm not really sure why that's
happening sometimes because sometimes it
hits the puck perfect and then sometimes
it's like swings in the absolutely wrong
direction
I think it's good oh it looks like it
went over the puck
do you work in C++ now the arms really
smash and stuff I tried to learn C++ Wow
yeah I think that's a ragequit on the
arm anyway
I try to learn C++ but the problem is
it's super frustrating when you're like
trying to make a project in C++ and how
long it takes and then you're like doing
the math constantly in your head how
quickly you could just do it in Python
and then I just go do it in Python so
just too tedious
yeah he's I'm done with this game I
think I'm gonna actually comment this
and this out that way we're not making
that request to the arm one last request
is fine
yeah the code is on github shift /
centex / u arm and then here's a direct
link to the to the code that's running
like right now open CPU works great with
C++ it works great with Python T though
in your opinion will AI develop an
intelligent on their own I feel like
with AI everything's inevitable right
like on a long enough time line will can
AI develop like an AI yeah I think the
only thing that is questionable to me is
whether whether an intelligence can
create an intelligence that's more
intelligent than itself and that's the
that's like the fundamental thing I have
with with you know the singularity and
all that is just like we have no reason
to believe that an intelligence could
create an intelligence that's more
intelligent so until we have evidence of
that I don't think you could could go
for it where's my drink of choice water
unless you mean alcoholic beverages or
something but water coffee cup FA iced
black coffee
you don't need six question marks man
hey maybe it's a serious question
Yeah right so like if a human could
create an intelligence smarter than
itself then that would be evidence that
an intelligence could do such a thing
and then with like an intelligence a
software-based you just you make lots of
copies so if like 5,000 copies of an AI
could make a single AI more intelligent
than any one of the copies of AI that
you know put it together then then you'd
have then you could see a scenario like
a singularity but again even to have
something like the singularity like an
intelligence explosion take place you'd
you'd need to have the processing power
and unless we can also simultaneously
like use the intelligence to figure out
how to more efficiently do the
processing or something like that just
don't see it happening but on a long
enough timeline I feel like at least AI
making another intelligence that's
really no different than what we've done
as humans right like we've made
intelligences like AI so of definitely
AI could write another intelligence but
would it be smarter I'm not sure
did someone I actually asked my opinion
on Iran that's a great question yeah
what do you think about Iran in the USA
yeah who cares what I think on that
honestly
yeah I with playing cs:go with a neural
network probably it would probably be
more likely object detection based I'd
like to definitely check out the you
only look once compare that to the cocoa
model that I've done but I wouldn't mind
it especially like with csgo you could
play indoors so that kind of negates the
problem that we were talking about
earlier with like playing like fortnight
or pub G both of those you have to your
your biggest task in those games is like
determining is something a bush or a
player or a you know tree or her players
something like that that's a very
challenging task to do with image
recognition because you're gonna be you
just would have a hard time getting a
good framerate but if you could play
like in a in a building or something
like that you could make a pretty darn
good AI I think a very challenging one
anyways so kristef I wouldn't even say
AI is more intelligent at specific tasks
I would say AI is more like efficient or
something like that at specific tasks
but you know like a computer is more
efficient at doing mathematics than a
human but are they more intelligent I I
think you'd you'd be hard-pressed but
you also have to define what you what
you mean by intelligence I suppose
my puck teepee use I've never been able
I haven't used one so I really can't
answer that I applied to get access to
one because I was curious how they would
how they would be but I couldn't get it
get that out of the corner
oh my gosh I was really hoping it would
solve this
you can you can get a TPU on Google
cloud a lot of times any of those like
high processing power things you still
have to like apply for why doesn't it
move backwards and then horizontally
because the code doesn't exist for that
if you want make a pull request make it
happen man a poker playing AI
[Music]
doesn't have to play with like physical
cards
why didn't you accept my poll requests
nmt I haven't looked at the nmg nmt chat
pod and github in a while also that's
Daniels you should ask Daniel why he
didn't accept it
am I using tight necks no I've had not
good success with the Titan cards both
the tight necks and tight necks Pascal
both kind of burned out on me that was
from the the GTA series both of them are
actually in boxes I don't know if you
can see the box behind me Canyon I don't
think you can anyway they're in boxes
right now they just they crash a lot
I kind of just want to like tape these
pieces of cardboard in the corner just
to stop it going in there did you go to
college yeah went to college I double
majored criminal justice and philosophy
sell them to minors they crash I don't I
think people would be irritated
autonomous flying with the quadcopters
no I haven't
I'd really like to I think that'd be a
lot of fun I have like the stuff with
the Raspberry Pi but the problem is the
Raspberry Pi just can't calculate quick
enough and I think it's called like a
navvy o na VI oh yeah Navi o - it's like
a hat that sits on top of a Raspberry Pi
and that's supposed to be pretty good
for for controlling quadcopters I've
just never never tried it out I think at
one point I tried to get them to send me
one I can't remember what what the
result of that was I don't know anything
about the gtx 1100 series honestly i
would my opinions always based on
performance - price so like the Titan V
for example it's just way overpriced for
what it is so I mean if they keep
releasing way overpriced cards I'm not
impressed
thanks Kevin
so I really think I'm gonna just tape
these little pieces of cardboard in the
corner I'm worried that it's going to
just hit the hit the striker though and
like drop it
what's my approach to getting started
with something new just start trying to
solve whatever the problem is that
you're trying to do I really just I
guess it kind of depends on what you're
talking about but break it down into ton
of tiny steps cent decks are you
literally just responded cardboard away
see what happens yeah I just feel like
if it was angled like that to be less
likely but then it'll still get stuck
like behind the arm but seems way more
calm and then it guides it into a corner
than anything else don't do it again
when are you gonna do audio processing
with them out not sure I'd like to do
I'll probably do tensorflow at j/s
before I do any audio processing so
probably sometime after that I don't
know how to do audio processing to be
honest it's all I'm just gonna be
winging it so you may or may not want to
see it
how would you cope video summarization I
think that's a Kaggle challenge that's
going on right now
more speed the problem with the arm
speed you can get it to go quicker but
it starts getting like real jittery we
can we can up the speed a little bit and
see what happens but a lot of times it
starts going kind of crazy
amen
it dunce hat what you doing there man
I think he's pressing too hard I'm gonna
reset him and he's gone down every time
he makes a swing I'm lowering it just
ever so slightly and I think that's
causing trouble
I feel like I have changed nothing I
wonder if the lighting is causing
trouble or something because he keeps
detecting over here I think it's I think
it's probably cuz it got a little
brighter or something like the sun's
come up see
first let's turn off auto focus while
we're here no sir
let's save it there you think I should
make lighting better yeah
what time is it 10:30 a.m.
score
it's not too bad when you cheat with
some pieces of cardboard that seems to
be working
what time do I rise kind of varies
somewhere between six and seven usually
what algorithm is it using follow the
puck and then hit the puck that's about
it is that the maximum force no the arm
can definitely hit a little harder but
it's like this super balancing act
between not not like yeah I don't think
early overheating the arm but the little
motors get kind of pissy do you ever get
tired standing at your desk no not
really
I have the only thing is like your feet
as long as you have like a little foot
mat or something and you don't stand in
your shoes then it's good so if you have
what I work or something and you have to
stand in shoes I think my feet would get
tired but I'm allowed to be barefoot
favorite YouTube channels hmm really
just like car channels to be honest I
don't really watch like program or
anything like that except for like when
I'm trying to learn something but
there's never really like one source get
it cool so maybe now we can try to speed
up the arm a little bit and see what we
can get away with
so I changed I think part of the problem
too is just issuing these commands to
the arm consistently so I mean I can add
this back I think the top speed up here
was 700 so one of the issues that I like
these commands right here timeout
so that camp sending the commands so
that was one issue I've seen so like we
ideally to hit the puck as hard as
possible we'd want to have it as fast
like this but you know raising these
like raising up the acceleration so this
is just the acceleration command so the
motors like kind of slowly get up to
speed but if we raise them up real fast
like this it'll go like it'll hit really
hard and then but then you want to set
the speed back down because you don't
want to always be at 5,000 because the
arm gets real finicky but these commands
were timing out on me before so I don't
really think this is gonna be a solution
but we can we can try a real quick just
to see if it'll how that'll do
I've know it where did the puck go is
the puck on the bull see like under the
arm I don't even see it
yeah it is see it's it's so much harder
I went over it no
I kind of want to just fix the striker
and see if it'll get itself out of this
scenario it looks like it did
Oh miss
nice
see now it's kind of yeah it does like
it'll start freaking out like that man
this thing is scoring all the time now
my little concrete barriers aren't doing
so well
isn't it pretty successfully right now
the whoa what's going on with that servo
what the heck I really don't know why
switch to serve around
that's shouldn't have done that do you
remember it's for school um no I don't
remember which one was his first goal I
feel like yesterday it was probably it's
for school looks for a while it couldn't
even hit the puck hard enough to get to
the goal hard-coded right now so the
idea is to just hard coat it just to get
it to the point where where it can score
at least once in a while and then you
could take dang that's some hard hitting
and then you could take it to the point
where it you could take the the training
data where it scores well and then and
use that to train a neural network and
then again just kind of let it explore
random parameters and then continue
training on just every time the model
gets better I don't know it just kind of
froze there anyway once it does start
scoring you can take all the scoring
plays basically and use that as training
data see if you can figure out how to
get out of this order a second arm and
have a 1v1 or everybody should just
tweet at you Factory and tell them to
send me a second arm
I'll be right back
you
you
you
so this is you playing pretty good I
don't know if it actually froze in my
absence or not but some pretty good
school I did get stuck in the corner I
think when I came back though camera for
this it's a sea 920's hanging over the
board make a robot I really would love
to make a robot that could make another
robot like like a 3d print like this has
a little 3d printing attachment that'd
be so cool
it's a just 3d print like another bot
that could 3d print another bot that
would be pretty cool but how would you
do like the motors and all that it's
pretty much impossible
yeah I'm pretty sure with this this bot
alone there's another score with this
bottle own we could definitely we could
create a pretty decent training set for
data oh no you can do it man
nice got kind of angry there for a
minute buddy figured it out
do you think it's possible to reproduce
PI GTA on ps4 Xbox one I can't imagine
how that sounds really challenging and
for what look I'm not sure it'd be worth
going through all that effort
what neural network um agony is the one
that works honestly I don't know it's
pretty hard to know like what you're
gonna do out of the gate you you just
trial and error anybody that knows
exactly what model to use right away is
probably lying about it or they just got
lucky
who are you working for myself
code for a goalkeeper
yeah actually they'd be kind of
interesting like adversarial networks
one is a goalkeeper the other one just
tried to score on the goalkeeper it'd be
kind of interesting how do you determine
the learning rate loss rate basically am
i working for the NSA no I left the NSA
not really on the greatest terms let's
start a key bug business
wouldn't your training be a lot faster
with two arms yeah definitely just need
two arms
being had confirmed
ooh this one's gonna be a challenge I
don't think he's gonna get this out of
there make the second arm whoa
okay so that actually worked pretty well
I am pretty curious what if
yeah can you guys not hear the arm it
makes a lot of noise
just when he gets like angry though
yeah that speed is definitely too fast
it's gonna keep timing out
is it too loud well it's in a different
room I wouldn't hear it in my room if I
slept
third offer I would not trust the the
arm to hold my coffee for me have I been
to Europe the only country I've been to
in Europe is Italy I went there for my
honeymoon
so I can't really say any country in
Europe is my favourite
why don't I ignore your questions meshes
retracted
who doesn't decorate their wall with
quadcopters
okay so what's the arm doing right now
like what was he thinking about where do
I live
Alabama now
oh my god she destroyed the
I really carefully engineered those
barriers I don't know how they got
destroyed
[Music]
now I've never been to India there was
like some conference in India that tried
to get me to go promised conferences
they always want you to just go for free
so somehow you're supposed to go to the
conference and pay for food travel hotel
and then you talk for free at their
conference which they sell tickets to
and have sponsors it just doesn't make
any sense it's too expensive too nice
yeah so so predicting it's like the
pucks position I think would be the next
thing so you could easily take the puck
and just like take the motion from frame
to frame and then you could just you
know draw a line basically from that
point so you would know like where the
puck is going to go and then if it's
about to hit one of the edges just have
it refractor off the edge I don't know
what math you would use for that but
that's how you would do it I didn't even
touch it I don't know if you'll be able
to tell that as soon as I go over there
the arm fixed itself I don't know if it
detected the puck elsewhere because of a
shadow or what I was interesting
is this animal Network no not yet now
first you like first you take a rule
based or you could play it as a human
but you gotta make the training data
before you could do much else now
probably the next thing is one is just
doing trajectory because you would
definitely at least to strike the puck
you'd want to know the pucks trajectory
and then know which way you should have
to why does it keep getting stuck there
you would need to know which way you
should strike the puck for a trajectory
that would line up with wherever the
goal is now if I go over there and he
fixes himself I'm gonna be pretty angry
is it the shadow eye I can't see what's
going on next time I go over there I'm
gonna look but I just like walk over
knees okay okay I'll fix it
yeah but so I think it's the shadow but
is it detecting are you guys seeing it
detects the puck somewhere else when I
go over there okay now pay attention
although I really think it's actually
frozen I don't I'm sure right now yeah
it definitely started to detect a puck
like up here so just like took a swing
what's that Daniel losing track if you
mean freezing it definitely hasn't
frozen like it did before at all and I'm
actually running pretty significant
speeds especially on the strike like a
lot of times all the now it's kind of
problem but the puck is stuck a lot of
times I think if it doesn't detect the
puck it doesn't show up here I think is
the issue or actually that was a timeout
this is a straight-up timeout there for
some reason and that seems to happen
over here for whatever reason I'm not
really sure why yeah all all uh
basically like all conference speakers
do it for the like publicity so a lot of
times if you work for like a company or
something like that
the company will fund you going there
but like for someone like me why would I
go to a conference to speak for free
it's just because then it's just work
I'd rather just pay to go to the
conference I'm not going to the
conference in India that's what that's
the whole problem
is is just too expensive to get there
from the arm is moved itself you should
try factorio on stream I think Daniel
plays factorio but I don't know anything
about factorial
someone tell me what factorio is
[Music]
to delay your life node me and Daniel
have never met in real life
that's why I'm still very confused at
what's going on in factorio
[Music]
excuse crap I should Bryce stay away
from his game then
[Music]
she's automation
none of YouTube video yeah the video
didn't really seem to explain to me what
what factorio is gonna be honest
why do you use Chrome in incognito mode
so default usernames and passwords or
whatever are not filled in for everybody
on stream who doesn't
yeah he is an incognito the man can't
track you at all so that's that's really
the reason I'm using it why doesn't want
to get stuck in exactly that location
sounds a good luck he's legit nom illage
it's noted wow he's just gone too crazy
I think it's pressing down too hard at
this point
yeah I think I think it was pressing
down too hard and that's why I wasn't
going all the way to the corner I'm not
really sure I still can't figure out so
like over time the arm press the arm
like wants to raise on that z-axis
really really slowly so I have it every
time it makes a strike lowers on the
z-axis really really slowly but that
that seems to be still too fast
see you later
score
I mean I'm sure oh you think it's
getting stuck in the corner because of
this shadow it's possible I could put a
light over it or something
hmm
how many hours on average it takes to
become good at building neural networks
I don't know man
I guess it depends on where you started
with and what you'd mean by good really
building neural networks is just kind of
trial and error got froze that time
how many years does it take I don't
think it takes years I mean obviously if
you're starting as not a programmer
yeah it's possible we could improve
using like straight G code but I'm not
really sure and now things are freezing
for some reason like that freezing
wasn't happening earlier I don't know if
the arm is just getting warm or what got
it
get it
okay I'm getting hungry I think I'm
gonna go eat arms looking much better
someone has some trajectory code or
something or something they want to
improve with the with the script you can
submit it here the current code that I
used here was in today was air hockey
stream code so if you got some ideas for
improvement let me know is it only one
thread yeah it's on one thread right now
all right till next time